[music]
my name is Butch Swaim a farmer from
southeast Iowa also national promotional
director for the national farmers
organization NFO at Corning Iowa today
on our Midwest farm report we have a
number of guests that are interested in
the farming picture as a whole quite
interested in business and various other
interests from around the country and
I'd like to start out by introducing to
my extreme right over here Coleman Scott
a businessman in the Midwest and other
places throughout the country then to my
immediate right Jim Parker the Parker
vacuum-cleaner supply company of Des
Moines Iowa and then on my left I have
Ed Shima a large farmer from over in
Iowa County Iowa that helps in his spare
time to get people to understand the
farm problem to get others to see that
we farmers should work together to solve
this problem and to start off with today
we would like to bring a few figures
here in a recent survey that was made of
the Sioux City, Iowa livestock market now
on one given day there was enough hogs
and enough cattle on this particular
market that we want to show you the loss
of income that is taking place in rural
America there was receipts this
particular day and these are actual
receipts and actual prices that the
farmers received neveress receipts this
particular day of twelve thousand ninety
nine head of cattle and the top price
was twenty one dollars now supposing
that everyone received the top price
which everyone knows they don't but
nevertheless they were still being
shortchanged at least $11.50 a-hundred
from the prices they should be to get
the farm prices and balance with the
rest of it
and the same has been figured out on
hogs and it was found that in this one
day's marketing the farmers in the area
around Sioux City, Iowa marketing area
along with shortchanged one million, six hundred,
and four thousand, a hundred and
ninety three dollars just on one day's
marketing this is the astounding figure
that has caused the businessmen of rural
America is causing them I should say to
wake up and find out that the farm
problem is not just a problem of the
farmers but a problem of everyone in the
United States and first I would like to
call on Mr. Coleman Scott who
is a businessman advertising business
various other things why don't you tell
us Coleman how your business is and how
it affects you as you see it well butch
I think probably the most important part
of it as it immediately appeared to me a
few days ago I was in one of the areas
not to very far from Des Moines talking
with a man in the automobile business
now this man does all of his business
with what we call rural America about 95
percent of all of his business is done
directly with the farmer I was talking
with him about a problem which was quite
important to him and it was important to
me because he was a part of an
advertising campaign which my firm was
about to handle and he said truthfully
Coleman I don't want to do any more
business well this is up obviously
something that is very strange because
here's a man that is not only a good
merchant but he has a record of being a
good businessman
and I said what causes you to make a
statement like that or he reached in his
desk for a stack just about this side
and he said all of these represent a
series of people with whom I've done
business with for years who have had
excellent records of pay these people
are now all delinquent this has now
forced me to become de liquid at the
bank this has never happened since I've
been in business in my conversation he
went on to say it's very tough for me to
sell something to a grocer for instance
who does business with a farmer when the
farmer doesn't have any money now over
and over I guess all of us have heard
the story of the farmer who benefits to
the extent of having two Cadillacs one
for town a one to drive down in the
South Forty this automatically caused
me to ask questions from him it was this
that caused me to first make my visit to
you to ask for additional information
NFO was comparatively new to me I've of
course seen it read it as a as a newsman
I've been in cut in touch with it to a
large degree because I've come in
contact with certain activities certain
things that have been said certainly
their national meetings and frankly
butch I wondered who it was that was
opposing the farmer from getting his
legitimate share of the National part of
the gross national product this was what
first caused me to ask these questions
of you now at your office I picked up a
sheet of paper it's a pink one here this
is obviously something people may see I
guess the cameras not turned on it but
it impressed me because I had recently
driven through the area- pardon me- which
was mentioned in this particular article
was referring to a particular part of
one county of the state of California
which to a large degree is owned by a
major land corporation now this company
has a holding of two million four hundred
and twelve thousand a hundred and twelve
acres now this is one company now if
somebody were to call this corporate
farming this would obviously make a lot
of sense but that isn't the truth
because in addition to owning this two
million four hundred thousand acres
they're also the largest producer of
livestock in one of the foreign
countries they own 51% of the stock in a
major implement corporation but their
big cash return comes from the 27
percent oil depletion benefits which
they enjoy through the series of the one
thousand five hundred and fifty
producing oil wells which are on there
two million four hundred and fourteen
thousand acres so they produce cattle
enjoying a tax benefit from
the oil depletion of the twenty seven
and a half percent allowance and
suddenly you're not talking about
farming anymore you're talking about
people in a variety of businesses the
strangest part was not their holding of
this but the fact that their board of
directors also had members of the board
of directors of one of the largest food
chains in the United States now in
reading some of your material which was
placed at my disposal I noticed that
many times many of those people had been
most belligerent in opposing the farmers
position for collective bargaining what
is this story Butch well this story is
to make a long story short come right to
the point here I don't know if the
camera can see this or not but in the
October convention of the chain stores
why the vice-president of the chain
stores called for an out-and-out
abolishment of the family farm system of
agriculture in America but what's the problem I
don't know really unless it's because
the fact that in the next 35 years the
amount of food produced in the United
States is going to have to weigh more
than double we're going to have have to
double everything virtually in America
with the exception of the tombstones out
here in the graveyard Coleman and
Agriculture has produced seventy percent
of the new wealth that goes into the
money streams of America to keep our
industry running and it's very obvious
that some of the large interests would
like to own control agriculture this is
the only reason that I can see they
didn't say why they attacked of the
family farm system agriculture but
nevertheless they call for the abolishment
of the family farm system of
Agriculture well now one of the things
that I have noticed the National farm
breeders the breeders of cattle those
who are feeders of cattle consistently
point to the amount of money that has
been lost by the cattle raisers yet one
of the largest rubber companies in the
United States maintains ten thousand
head of cattle on one of its ranches
again enjoying a series of the twenty
seven percent oil depletion it's pretty
tough it would seem to me for a man who
raises a hundred head to be able to
compete with this kind of an operation
well NFO would correct this situation
because the people that all the people
that grow a hundred head would band
together and would equal ten thousand
head in in a lot in other words it would
equal anything far greater than all the
rest of them own put together this is
what the family farm must do they must
band together through the NFO
collective bargaining plan so that their
bargaining strength is not only just as
great as any other food producers in the
United States but is greater then the
bargaining power of those that are
buying the farm commodities well I had a
man pardon me Butch I had a man explaining
to me I asked some questions
of people in the processing business
today knowing that I was going to appear
with you and he said Coleman it's probably
the strangest situation that exists he
said we in turn create a processed meat
product we know what we have to sell it
for because the people we're going to
sell it to tell us what they want to
sell it for they're going to add their
profit and we work backwards they're
going to sell it for 69 cents we know
what their markup is so we know what
we're gonna sell it to them for him by
the time we finally reached the point
where we buy the product that's going to
go into it we have to say to the farmer
this is all we can tell you because
that's all there is now everybody
else's profit had been added to it now
they were at the point of origin this is
exactly opposite of any other
manufactured product in America this is
exactly right and this is why the
farmers must act and act now because
their whole industry is in jeopardy and
everyone else in America sets their
price based on a cost of production and
then a reasonable profit why shouldn't
the American farmer be entitled to do
the same thing to start at the origin of
the product in other words maybe to set
a price of it based on what they know
it's going to cost to produce it before
it to the crop is ever planted before
this operation starts and then ask and
receive that price well Butch of course
the biggest the biggest argument against
well let's take one particular item the
biggest argument of course against the
business of the farmers collective
bargaining has been the fact that you'd
price yourself out of the European
markets in the foreign markets now I
found that interesting reading well
where's this
to me isn't a problem because why should
we depend on the European market for a
living when we have plenty here in
America why should we depend on the
European market last year Coleman we did sell
one acre and four out of each four in
foreign trade but you know why
we sold one acre and four in foreign
trade for the simple reason that we
couldn't make a living on the three
acres that we sold at home
so we built a surplus product so we
build a surplus and we operate wholly in
surplus so there's only one difference
no doubt you realize this much better
than I would
or much better than the average farmer
out here but did you ever stop to think
with the only difference between a
surplus or a so-called surplus and an
inventory is to set the price on it
so we at NFO believe that we
should get together and set the price on
our commodity change our so-called
surplus into an inventory just like any
other good business in America does
well Butch I was in your office as you will
recall when Jim Parker another
businessman walked in and asked almost
identically the same type of questions I
asked so I was real pleased when you
said Jim and I would be together in the
same show this is ironic folks these are
two businesspeople that walked in the
office the very same day within a matter
of a few minutes apart concerned about
the same things concerned that their
business was going down with the farmer
so that farming the farm problem is no
longer just the problem of the Farmers
of America but it's a problem of all
America and at this time I would like to
to ask Jim Parker to express his
business views and why we walked into
the office and why but his he told it as
he put it and I want him to explain it
in his own words a little later and, as
he, the more and more that he looked at
this farm situation the more that he
felt the noose tightening around his
neck but he would no longer be in
business if the NFO should fail and this
was just two days ago I never saw the
man before but he's a real shrewd
businessman
folks and i would like to express get
him to express his opinion why it is
that he thinks as he put it to me that
every businessman in America should be
concerned and every businessman could
should be willing and ready to help
solve this farm problem
well Butch this is an unpaid
testimonial I agree unpaid for sure but
whether or not it'll be a testimonial
depend the course on whether or not I
can learn a little about the NFO and
that's my reason for being here that's
my reason for having come into the
office my business consists of
contacting dealers in small communities
through Iowa northern Missouri little of
Kansas a little of eastern Nebraska and
about two years ago I began to feel this
pinch I put a dealer in a little town of
Pattonsburg Missouri and I come back
six weeks later to call on him and he
was gone
now this has happened a number of times
I'm becoming aware and I had become
aware at that time that this little
businessman in this town when he tells
me he doesn't have the money to buy
today I contacted approximately six
dealers that told me this and these
dealers were well-established had been
in business for a number of years and
they feel it
if these dealers are affected then
they're going to be other businessmen
surely like me I would presume several
businessmen who have already been put
out of business I'm on the verge at
least in this phase of it I come into
your office in the hope that I could
find out something from NFO I've
been concerned about this holding action
some people agree with it some people
disagree but one thing about it I was
favorable to the NFO because they're
doing something I saw these television
programs that you have had on Sunday
afternoon and they  were good they
had they had good effect I like the I
like the way they go about this thing
they're going to make an effort to do
this
if they can find a way to bring to the
attention of the businessman to the Iowa
citizen to the citizens of this country
the fact that we surely got to take care
of our farm program we've surely got to
get the economy of the farmer right
every time isn't it true that every time
a farm closes goes out of business
we die a little more yes this is true
and we lose more business people all the
time I'm real glad Jim that you brought
up this fact of the NFO holding action
because this is probably the most
misunderstood thing there is about our
whole program but I'd like to call your
attention in fact with everybody in
America that's in business every working
man that works for a wage all of them
have a holding action all the time did
you ever stop to think that you have a
holding action on your on your business
all the time that you set a price on
your commodity and you hold for that
price but simply this has been
established before you were entered
business to the point that everybody
walks in or that buys from you pays
this price without ever thinking that
you have a holding action and the fellow
that you sell it to from the wholesale
level he has a holding action too he
holds it until he gets this price he
puts the legitimate market based on a
cost of production plus a profit the
same way you operate your business and
he has a holding action now is it so
wrong or the American farmer to do
exactly the same thing we hope to
educate the people and the public that
we're entitled to a cost of production
plus a reasonable profit and then as
soon as they become aware of this
situation and acknowledge this fact then
we will no longer have to have a holding
action such as we had before that you're
referring to this holding actions we've
had in the past have been to call
people's attention for the situation and
to test our bargaining strength with the
processor the very much the same way
that a labor union for instance has a
test of strength when they have a
walkout
or at least to gain the same respect that
everyone else has the right to set down
and bargain in America for a fair price
Jim this basically is NFO are we moving- is
it moving forward now moving forward
real well we've been expanding into many
more states recently where we have
somewhere in the neighborhood of two or
three hundred people that are working
whatever time they can out in the area
we're gaining very rapidly at this time
I made this statement many times and
it's true it's been proven true all the
time but everyone in America will
support the NFO plan of action will
support the NFO efforts as soon as they
understand again in fact is I will make
this statement to anyone anywhere in
America that's against the principles of
the National Farmers Organization are
against American form of government and
I say this for two reasons
that number one it's been the law of our
land for some 23 years now it's been
legal for the farmers to band together
and organize and do exactly what the NFO
is doing and number two it's the same
business principle that everyone else in
America uses all the time every day that
they're open for business right now can
I make another point Butch just before
you leave me here every community in
Iowa at least every little town that I
go to when I Drive down the Main Street
I see empty buildings businesses used to
be in these buildings but now they're
not there anymore
we can't pin this all down to one little
community or one group of communities
just recently I drove down the Main
Street of Cedar Rapids from Marian
driving west down First Avenue and right
down in the heart of the middle of Cedar
Rapids in in an area of a block or a
block and a half I counted four or five
empty buildings now here's one of our
leading cities in the state of Iowa
Coleman you you saw this yeah I saw that
the thing that the thing that impresses
me when I see such a thing is I wonder
what it was that caused a businessman
who had an investment in a community to
say it's got me I can't take it I wonder
what it was that caused
this man to say there is no future in
business and get out of it now this is
what scares me when I see that do you
think it's all of the farm, to
attribute it to the to the farm economy
no I don't attribute it to the farm
economy if I did I wouldn't I wouldn't
keep asking questions I don't know who's
to blame
I keep wondering these points if a man
who works in a factory does not make
enough money to pay the milk bill I know
he can't buy milk so the government says
to him look we're gonna give you free
milk right now this doesn't make sense
to me somebody should pay him enough
money so they can go buy the milk right
but if they do this why did- they why did
the milk cost 30 cents a quart when it
gives given away free to him because he
didn't have enough money to get it and
the farmer got six and a half cents a
quart for the milk anyway that he can't
buy it either if the farmer didn't have
the milk on the farm he doesn't make
enough money to bought it either
now if the farmer does not produce a
milk product he can't buy milk for his
kids today in many cases now this is the
thing that causes me to ask why if
work is work and labor is honest I
started to ask a question a moment ago
here butch says this has been going on
for 20-some years actually Arthur capper
who was the great friend of the farmer
originated the act in 1922 the
capper-volstead, 43 years 43 years
that's what I was going to correct you
on but thank you for letting me
interrupt I didn't mean to and now we're
going to turn to farmer the fellow that
farms for a living raising his family
doing a real good job farming one of
them more or less a big scale not real
big scale but as far as a family farm it's
considered a real bit operation a good
50 operation an operation where
efficiency is practiced
where's diversified he raises a number
of things and Ed would you care to
fill in as you see it what is the
solution of this farm problem so-called
farm problem well butch we have in my
community over the years a number of our
really what you'd call good farmers have
been leaving and this trend is
continuing as I see it looking at my
community we're by and large we are
all of us are pretty efficient farmers
we have rather large operations we
aren't what you'd call marginal farmers
at all but still when I look at the my
neighbors practically all of them almost
without exception are working in the
town to supplement their farm income or
if they aren't their wives probably are
almost without exception now this is a
great concern actually then you look at
the community I live in fairly good land
and fairly good-sized farm operations
but still they aren't making a go of it
now over the years we've seen these
house farms be become larger being
consolidated and going into the future I
think this is going to continue then as
you look at these farms now they're
large investments it's hard to finance
this type of operation as they continue
to get bigger I can I wonder
who's who's going to finance these
certainly the family type farmer can't
continue to finance a large-
larger operation under the present
income structure that we have so then
the question is what should we do about
this and as a farmer in Iowa County Iowa
it seems to me that we need to look at
this in a more businesslike way do like
businessmen do put ourselves in a
business position of pricing our
products and in doing this this requires
some responsibilities you have to accept
some responsibility to price your
product you have to accept the
responsibility for the surpluses the
market might not absorb at this price
you have to accept the responsibility
for an even flow into the market you
have to be in a position to convince a
consumer that this product is worth is
this increased priced or and without
elaborating on these points I think that
there's no question what there's only
one solution to this problem today as I
see it and that's the National Farmers
Organization I think that until farmers
are willing to put their heads together
in terms of marketing I don't believe
that there's too much hope in improving
the farm situation today thank you ed
and I think you did a real good job
summing it up I'd like to touch on what
it really cost not to have the farmer in
balance with Reston
it not only cost the farmer it costs all
of our total economy fact is a survey
made by the independent bankers
organization this is the small banks or
rural banks of America where the new
wealth originates they've made a survey
and they prove beyond a shadow of a
doubt had the farmers been paid in
balance with the workingman and with
interest that our total national economy
would have been 303 billion I said
billion dollars more than it would have
been in 1963 in other words it would
have been 50 percent higher everyone in
America would have profited by increased
farm prices because this price would
necessarily have to raise at all to the
consumer
fact is consumers were paying far more
for a pound of beefsteak
when we were getting 32 dollars and a
half or 32 and a half cents a pound for
our cattle on the hook and we were
getting 24 to 25 dollars for hugs then
they were paying far less for food than
they are now the Department of
Agriculture shows that while food prices
have gone up 29 percent to the consumer
the prices that the farmer received for
the same amount went down some 12 to 15
percent so I don't know Coleman who's
getting this but I'm beginning to wonder
like you who is it when it will help
everybody help the total economy and
help everybody in America who is it that
would hold down the farmer what is the
ulterior motives behind it to starve out
the family farm in America there's no
question about it
now the independent bankers made a
little bit farther study they showed
that if the farmer had been in balance
with the rest of the economy that he
would have had twenty one and eight
tenths billion dollars more than he did
receive in 1963 or in other word folks
for every dollar that the farmer got to
keep or was able to keep in his business
as income he was cheated out of
approximately $2 by somebody somebody
got about $2 that should belong to the
farmer now had this happened rural or
business and professional income would
have been 11 billion dollars more rental
income would have been 4 and 5/10
billion dollars more corporate profits
of America would have been 10 and 4/10
billions more in other words forget the
farm income up where it belongs would
cost
nobody anything wouldn't cost anything
at all because the total economy would
far more than make it back the working
man would get much more income or an
opportunity to work more hours for
instance in the loaf of bread the farmer
only receives about 2 and a half cents
of it anyway
so if bread went up 1 cent a loaf the
farmer would get 2 or 300 percent more
profit than he gets off in the wheat
that's in the loaf of bread
so as you see it costs nobody anything
to get the farm price up and it's
costing everybody it's costing them
billions of dollars three hundred and
three billion dollars gross national
product because they wouldn't let it
come up where it belongs now I wonder why
and I would like to say this to you with
all sincerity if you're not opposed to
all this new wealth coming into rural
America at decent farm prices it's time
that you begin to look around as these
businessmen have done begin to look
around and see and wonder who is causing
the farm prices to be low who is getting
this extra money that all should be
available to the farmers and to all of
our economy on an equal basis I think
it's time that we look around now in
closing I would like to call on the rest
of the farmers in America to become good
businessmen and women and set our
pattern up in a businesslike structure
and operate our business by all except a
good business principles
this program today has been brought to
you by the farmers in this listening
area and others interested in seeing the
farmer get a fair price tune in again
next week for more information and join
the farmers of America to solve the
[music]
next week for more information and join
the farmers of America to solve the
problem thank you